يعني البسمه لا تفارق وجههما الان حتى
الان نحن نعرض هذه الصور على العربيه
نتابع علي وريانا والفرحه ظاهره والحماس
ظاهره على تعبير وجههما ويلقيان التحيه
على كل من يقف امامهما يوقعان الان طبعا
هذه لحظه تاريخيه تستحق التاكيد وتستحق
الثقه وتستحق ايضا الفخر بان يشعراء
بالفخر لانهما يمثلان وطنهما وللمره
الاولى يمثلان الشباب الشباب العربي
الشباب السعودي والمسلم وخصوصا ايضا
بالنسبه لريانه التي تعد مفخره لبنات
وطنها وحتى ايضا بنات العرب لكي تكون اول
عربيه مسلمه شابه ايضا تخرج الى الفضاء
اليوم يتم الحديث بان السعوديه الى الفضاء
في ظل هذه المرحله وما ستتبعها ايضا من
مراحل متعدده فيما يتعلق بالاستكشافات
التي ستخدم البشريه على صعيد انجازات طبيه
لانه ايضا هناك الحديث عن الطب في الفضاء
سيكون الاستفاده من التجارب التي ستتم
خلال 12 يوما في هذه المهمه وما سيتبعها
ايضا من مهمات اخرى وارسال رواد فضاء
اخرين نتابع معكم ما زلنا ننقل لكم هذه
الصور التي تريدنا طبعا الاستعدادات على
قدم وساق وصل الرواد الاربعه الاثنان
امريكيان والسعوديان ايضا الاثنين وصل
الان
يوضع عن داخل هذه المركبه يتم ربطهم
باحزمه الامان كما نتابع ايضا البزه
الخاصه في الفضاء وكان ايضا مراسلنا في
فلوريدا حسين الطاوود تحدث وشرح لنا بان
هي بدلات خاصه صممت لكي تكون مهيئه في
الفضاء تحديد ننقل لكم اذا هذه الصور على
ما يبدو هناك استعداد كامل بدانا نشاهد
علي وريانا وهما يدخلان الى المركبه لكي
يلحقاه بزملائهما الرائده الرائدي الفضاء
الامريكيين الذين سيشاركهما في هذه الرحله
طبعا هذه الرحله توصف بانها رحله طموحه هي
جزء من برنامج السعوديه لرياده الفضاء
كانت اطلقته الهيئه العامه للفضاء وطبعا
مراسلنا ايضا هاني صفيان من قلب الحدث حيث
يتابع الجميع من هذه العامه للفضاء لتاهيل
طبعا كوادر سعوديه متمرسه للحديث عن خوض
رحلات فضائيه اما طويله المدى او قصيره
المدى اليوم نحن نتحدث عن هذه المهمه
التاريخيه ستكون لحوالي 12 يوما وستقوم
بعمل اربع تجربه علميه ستكون هذه التجارب
العلميه متعدده سيتم الاستفاده ايضا من
الفرص الواعده التي
ستقدمها هذه المهمه ويقدمها ايضا قطاع
الفضاء وصناعاته العالميه ايضا سيكون هناك
اسهام في الابحاث هذه التي ستاتي من هذه
المهمه طبعا ستصب في صالح خدمه البشريه في
عدد كبير من المجالات كنا تحدثنا مجالات
الصحه الطب في الفضاء كما اشرنا ايضا
نتحدث عن استدابه وايضا كما اشرنا الى
مساله تكنولوجيا الفضاء اليوم الكل يريد
ان يعرف اكثر فاكثر ماذا في الفضاء هل
يمكن العيش فعلا في الفضاء هل يمكن ان
يكون هناك كوكب اخر غير كوكب الارض يمكن
ان نذهب اليه هل ستكون هناك رحلات الى
الفضاء سياحه الى الفضاء بدل الحديث في
الاونه الاخيره عن مساله السياحه الى
الفضاء كل الامور بخدمه رواد الفضاء وهذه
الرحلات الاستكشافيه سيكون هناك اجوبه عده
ستجيب عن كل الاستفسارات والتساؤلات لدى
العالم وحتى ستفسر كثير من العلم الذي
يطرح في الاونه الاخيره طبعا كنا تحدثنا
بان الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء كانت نشرت في
صور عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي تحديدا
تويتر صور لمنصه الاطلاق كانت ايضا اظهرت
السداد صاروخ فالك 9 طبعا هذا الصاروخ
مركبه دراغون التي كما نتابعها الان هذه
المركبه التي ستحمل رواد الفضاء الاربعه
ضمن هذه المهمه التي ستنطلق اليوم بعد
منتصف الليل بتوقيت المملكه العربيه
السعوديه هذه المهمه مهمه اي اكس تو ستذهب
الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه طبعا كان حماسه
شديده لكل من رائد الفضاء علي القرني الذي
كان ايضا شاركنا بصور له وهو
يستعد ويحمل ايضا حقيبته وهذه المحتويات
التي سيضعها في الحقيبه للسفر الى الفضاء
ريان ايضا كانت نشرت وشاركتنا عبر تويتر
بهذه الصور
للاستعدادات وايضا للتدريب وحتى المراجعات
الاخيره
للانطلاق نحو محطه الفضاء الدوليه هناك
ايضا انظر كلها تتجه نحو هذه المهمه التي
توصف بانها الرحله السعوديه الى الفضاء
الاعين الان ايضا نحو اول رائده فضاء
سعوديه وعربيه ومسلمه حيث سينطلق رائده
الفضاء السعوديان الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه
اي اس اس في رحله طبعا هذه رحله هي رحله
علميه تمثل تاريخيا بالنسبه للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه وايضا تدشن مرحله جديده
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه في مجال الفضاء
نحن ننقل لكم هذه الصور طبعا كما نشاهد
الرواد الاربعه جاهزون ايضا تم ربطهم
باحزمه الامان نتابع معكم هذه الصور
والمشاهد لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات